eight seven six
five five four engine ignition two
one zero
related and liftoff as the countdown to
mars continues
the perseverance of humanity launching
the next generation of robotic explorers
to the red planet
and atlas tu has gone to close loop
control
[Music]
coming up on 30 seconds into flight the
rd-180 is throttling down as expected
engine response looks good
and mach 1 atlas 5 is now supersonic
and passing 45 seconds it is a beautiful
thing while joining me now to achieve
the fact on this subject is a francisco
diego senior research fellow at the
department of physics and astronomy at
the university college london francisco
uh
very warm welcome to you uh firstly what
more can you tell us about
what scientists are hoping to find oh it
is an amazing mission really
and they are choosing a fantastic
landing site which was a crater that was
expected well it was supposed to be
filled with water
billions of years ago with
water which was there for a long period
of time so one of the main purposes of
course is to find evidence for life that
maybe have appeared very primitive life
of course
that may have appeared at that time and
the
landing site is perfect to find out
evidence for that i mean
it will be kind of fossil evidence of
some kind of
of uh chemical or uh fingerprints of
biological activity in the very far past
fascinating indeed it is and unlike the
previous four
rovers nasa has sent to mars um the
perseverance
is equipped to directly detect life
either current or in a fossilized form
that's right um it has several several
experiments i mean this is just
an upgraded version of the curiosity
rover that was launched also very
successfully
a few years back and the uh the aim is
more or less similar although the
spectroscopic instrument is a little bit
more sophisticated
it has also a helicopter a kind of
a kind of drone helicopter that is going
to be tested to see
if he can fly in that very thin
atmosphere and also he's taking a little
bit of a mite meteorite that landed here
on earth coming from mars
and is taking this meteorite back to
mars in order to have something to
calibrate the spectroscopic instrument
according to what is finding on the on
the ground so amazing new uh
developments that is taking uh
uh to mars and once it does
arrive on mars it will begin that
process of returning rocks to earth for
analysis how exactly
will that be done oh well that is an
amazing
an amazing thing it's going to be in
several stages it's going to take
several years
what is going to do is to collect
samples
uh very very carefully selected samples
of the of uh special places where this
rover is going to be
put them in capsules and then a few
years later
another mission is going to come and
land and collect the samples
and bring the samples back to orbit from
european orbiter that is going to give
the samples there and then it's going to
be
to earth in in years and years to come
so it's a several stages
it's an amazing an amazing sequence of
events that is going to happen so this
is the first stage is to collect the
samples
leave them on mars be collected later
we've just witnessed the separation of
the rocket franciscan yes
i'm watching it's fantastic it's going
it's going very well
it is wonderful to it is wonderful to
watch isn't it um
we do also expect some remarkable new
imagery from
the cameras on the vehicle and also
sound is that difference
to um previous uh trips yes we have a
microphone already in one of the
landers uh some time ago that we could
record the winds of mars this mission
also the perseverance has also
microphones to record sounds
to give us a more vivid experience of
being on mars not only the very
nice images that we expect but also the
sound that comes with that
and francisco give us an idea of why
this is important how does this help us
here on earth
it is important for many reasons of
course is all the technology that's been
developed
and we are learning how to go and
explore another planet
and uh this rover has been extremely
very carefully there is a
kind of organization called in within
nasa called the planetary protection
this rover and everything that goes with
it and they land on the lander
have been very extremely uh sterilized
because we don't want to contaminate
the planet where we are going to find
life and we are going to find the life
that we took them
ourselves but also we are learning how
to
explore in a different way we are not
exploring that the way we discover
america
the continent and we kind of vandalize
it and
produce this kind of enormous
destruction that we still see today
is still going on today so we are
learning to collaborate
emissions with europe with japan with
russia
with uh india and china also other
partners that are
collaborating and i'm sure in a few
years to come
there will be a collaboration between
all these space agencies to really
put forces together because this is very
challenging missions to go there
we're planning to send astronauts in a
decade
so all these learning experiences
francisco wonderful to your enthusiasm
many thanks indeed for
joining us here on sky news